mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
kulturplatz beschäftigt sich auch heute
mit fragen rund um corona was machen
kulturschaffende ohne rücklagen für die
es jetzt finanziell richtig eng wird
wie gehts sängerin regula mühlemann im
home office
[Musik]
der philosoph slavoj zizek und die polit
philosophin katja gentinetta denken
darüber nach ob die korona krise
womöglich das ende des neoliberalismus
bedeutet und wie die gute idee von drei
musikern alten und kranken durch diese
zeit hilft
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja wir
machen heute in basisstation hier im
meret oppenheim hochhaus hier ist die
saf kulturabteilung zu hause und damit
auch wir vom kulturplatz und hier gibt
es ab sofort eine bühne für die
kulturschaffenden natürlich unter der
nötigen sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
leider auch ohne live publikum aber
alles was hier geboten wird ist für sie
daheim gedacht und das ist heute eine
gute portion musik später in der sendung
ist die sopranistin regula mühlemann bei
uns zu gast sie würde im sommer bei den
salzburger festspielen auftreten aber
nichts ist mehr sicher
in diesen zeiten und darüber werde ich
mit ihr sprechen zuerst aber schauen wir
auch diese woche
wie ist die situation bei den schweizer
kulturschaffenden wie prekär ist ihre
lage und was können sie selbst dagegen
tun
mach mal halblang corona was du heute
kannst besorgen verschiedene auf morgen
schabbat dauert an
manche künstler nehmen es mit
galgenhumor
denn die lage ist eigentlich gar nicht
mehr lustig wir haben allenfalls noch
geld für einen monat und dann sollte der
virus vorbei sein oder mit kunst die
beiden freischaffenden zürcher künstler
willi und amos haben kein erspart ist
sie handelten sich bisher von projekt zu
projekt die krise trifft sie nun umso
härter das ja viel versprachen sich also
mehr hätten als boulahrouz brach mit dem
patrick frey hätte das billboard
aufgestellt wurden vom zugesichert
werden dass oxytocin kulturfolger im
august auf italien gehen war für das
halbes jahr
ja das ist mir etwas stattfindet wird
mit der situation jetzt also ja es macht
das strich betrachtet
die beiden haben anspruch auf die
nothilfe des bundes maximal 196 franken
pro tag doch das eigentliche problem ist
ein anderes
der bereich der kreativschaffenden war
schon immer prekär gratisarbeit kleinst
verdienste selbstausbeutung die kultur
lebt oft von idealismus stadt von fairer
bezahlung valley fragilität von system
spürt man jetzt wo ja nicht durch kroner
kreiert ist sondern wo krone eine kuh
verlegt das prekariat die enorme
abhängigkeit von kulturschaffenden
kulturinstitution von funktionierenden
markt
abhängig von einem funktionierenden
markt sind auch die vielen menschen die
in der kultur im hintergrund arbeiten
jenseits des scheinwerferlichts wie zb
die freiberufliche bühnenbildnerin
melanie siedler
für sie sind nun alle aufträge
weggebrochen job verlor
doch das und ich habe mich zuerst in
rafah malta ich weiß aber nicht wo ich
im beruf halt immer man trennt stelle
findet in die zukunft rente stelle
finden auf nothilfe hat sie keinen
anspruch da sie noch kleinere
ersparnisse hat auch die kantonale
ausfalls entschädigung könnte schwierig
werden da ihr beruf über unvorhersehbare
kurz arbeitsverträge funktioniert ich
habe ihn nicht definieren was mir
eventuell entgangen war dass rimes
finanziell nicht ganz so prekär ist die
situation der schriftstellerin ariella
sabara vielmehr ist ihr kreatives werk
bedroht just vor der krise hat sie ihren
ersten roman herausgebracht eine
autobiografisch inspirierte mutter
tochter geschichte rund um das thema
sterbehilfe und den familiären umgang
damit
geplant wäre eine lesereise gewesen
podiumsdiskussionen die leipziger
buchmesse vor bisher geschafft hat und
dass das einfach dass er verschiedene
nötige reform kann stattfinden und wie
einen abbruch ariela sarbacher sucht nun
andere wege um ihr buch unter die leute
zu bringen
nutzt wie so viele in dieser zeit das
internet und prompt entsteht aus der
krise ein neues buchprojekt
ich habe plötzlich mein alltag
erfahrungen außergewöhnliche situation
beschrieben und schrieb jetzt eigentlich
stunde lang jeden tag haben ein
fixtermin ammerweg das ist mit poster
und jetzt fragen sich dann wie tritt
damit mache ob es wieder poster oder
wieder zurücknimmt summiert und auch im
blick für mich und alles wofür gibt soll
man sein kreatives schaffen einfach
gratis ins netz stelle einmal mehr
idealismus zeigen aber kein geld
verdienen
willi und amos sehen darin auch einen
ausweg aus der isolation eine
möglichkeit weiterhin mit dem kunstmarkt
zu kommunizieren meint die zehn firmen
studio habe investition wird zeichnete
rakusa wird verklärt wird finden wo man
online stellen fertig machen
ich glaube man deswegen für bild dann
werden wir diesen pragmatismus und
zuversicht der kulturschaffenden sind
angesichts der schwierigen situation
bemerkenswert die liebe zu kunst
übertrumpft anscheinend die akuten
probleme
das ist das neue kunstwerk versteht
alles wird gut
das leben ist eines der besten geld war
nie ein problem das wort geld steht auf
dem kopf wir werden sehen
[Musik]
die korona pandemie konfrontiert uns mit
umständen die wir nicht für möglich
hielten die welt wie wir sie kannten hat
aufgehört sich zu drehen was bedeutet
dass weit mehr als ein husten im
weltweiten system das behauptet der
philosoph slavoj zizek unter
prognostiziert uns ein ende des
kapitalismus so wie wir ihn kennen eine
welt ein virus krone kostet tausende
menschenleben und erschüttert die
globale wirtschaft das ist das ende des
kapitalismus wie wir ihn kennen kein
husten im system sondern fieberkurven
einer marktwirtschaft die immer mehr
wachstum geschwindigkeit und
ressourcenverbrauch verlangt
das lässt hlawatschek keine ruhe der
philosoph aus slowenien eine
intellektuelle naturgewalt epidemien wie
diese machen jetzt klar wo die grenzen
unseres weltweiten ich nenne es nicht
gerne so aber es ist so neoliberalen
wirtschaftssystems liegen
neoliberal bedeutet für scheck keinerlei
staatliche eingriffe in die freie
marktwirtschaft doch dieses system habe
sich überlebt die situation erinnere ihn
an quentin tarantinos kill bill 2 die
weltwirtschaft getroffen wie im film der
bösewicht
zuerst scheint der schlag aufs herz
nicht tödlich zu sein
doch der eindruck täuscht
der uneingeschränkte handel unsere
lebensader tödlich getroffen
wir fragen nach in der schweiz bei katja
gentinetta politische philosophin und
gewichtige stimme aus liberaler warte
[Musik]
doch hunde krise auf globalisierung zu
unserer ecke wo man mir erwartet hatte
der wird einiges in frage stelle
die lieferzeit die ist es wichtig die
zum teil wichtige abhängigkeiten von
daher wirklich so dass die kur oder
krise viel stärker in frage stellt aus
alles was bis jetzt denn der erreger
verbreitete sich als blinder passagier
über den globus
der weltweite kapitalismus
mitverursacher seiner eigenen krise
es brauche nun radikale veränderungen so
kritiker etwa höhere transportkosten um
unseren waren- und personenverkehr zu
zügeln
die pause die uns corona aufzwingt ein
startschuss in eine weniger am wachstum
orientierte wirtschaft
jetzt sei die politik gefordert sagt
scheck er ist fassungslos wenn
regierungen noch immer auf eigene faust
handeln statt solidarisch
wie kann man denn eine solche epidemie
in den griff bekommen ohne irgendeine
weltweite koordination
da bin ich stolz mit ihm einig wenn ich
jetzt nur auf italien und sehe wie
italien in der not für seine
europäischen partner im stich geworden
ist dann finde ich das
es ging um fehlende medizinische güter
nur schleppend lief letzte woche die
innereuropäische unterstützung an
da alte china italien zu hilfe und
inszenierte sich als retter in der not
manche finden nun der autoritären staat
bekämpfen die pandemie am effektivsten
eine gefährliche entwicklung
doch das chinesische regime handelt die
demokratischen eu länder zögern deshalb
stehe nicht nur die wirtschaftliche
ordnung auf dem prüfstand sondern die
politische findet katja gentinetta
systemwechsel kennt die ganz bös st das
ist nicht einfach kapitalismus ist
sondern von einer freien gesellschaft
ich habe spitze jetzt massiv aber wenn
wir schon gesehen wie sich wie sich die
großmacht jetzt positionieren und
insbesondere china global jetzt in
positionen könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass wird politische konsequenzen haben
das hat auch emanuel makro erkannt der
französische staatspräsident eigentlich
ein überzeugter neoliberaler denkt um
diese pandemie macht deutlich dass
manche güter und dienstleistungen nicht
den marktgesetzen satelliten dürfen
unsere ernährung unsere sicherheit
unseren schutz
die fähigkeiten unser leben zu gestalten
an andere zu delegieren ist verrückt
eine solche rückbesinnung etwa bei der
staatlichen beschaffung von
beatmungsgeräten oder der produktion von
impfstoffen dürfe aber nicht zu
protektionismus führen so gentinetta es
wichtiger ist dass mehr
versorgungssicherheit garantiert auf der
einen seite das war aber auf der anderen
sind jetzt effizienz aber der markt
bereit stellen nutzt und in deinem sind
aus dem markt was so besser effizienter
und damit der günstige funktioniert und
was will slawo scheck für die
gesellschaft einen systemwechsel hin zu
die globalisierung nein und nein sogar
mehr an globalisierung
jetzt heißt aber die losung eine andere
form der globalisierung finden
europa muss vereint sein
doch nicht einfach mit offenen grenzen
und dem wirtschaftlichen fragen etwa in
der landwirtschaft nein wir müssen jetzt
unsere aktivitäten koordinieren
mehr denn je
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja und da ist jetzt bio ist organistin
reglement die ganzen gut hilft
eigentlich singe auch um billy beane tag
ich muss ehrlich sagen die letzte partie
gar nicht zur verrichtung ich bin ist
immer gut aber sehen helfen natürlich
schon grundsätzlich jeder arbeitslose
und wieso hansele viel gesungen wird
immer schön ist müssen
nein ich habe wahnsinnig viel geschafft
die letzte wort meldet und für mich ist
sowieso ein klinikums zieht knie wohl
zeigen ganz willkommen
das heißt aber dass sie im moment noch
nicht an diese absage oder absage hand
über auftritte und stattfinden doch also
sind zwei konzerte abgesagt wurde sind
noch schweden von dem konzept haben
wenig freude ruft andere ist die sorge
macht ist die video seht ihr das schon
vorsorglich oder du bist im dezember
absage kassiert
ich weiß dass mit potenziellen
arbeitgebern nicht nur große staatliche
institutionen sind sondern auch innere
orchesters privat finanziert die
orchester obwohl man den aus gefragt wie
gottes in zukunft weiter ja und ein
großer meilenstein wäre ja im juli auf
seite ihre organe damit der salzburger
festspiele bis was ich freue mich sehr
darauf gefreut tiroler frauen beenden
und in euro vorstellen und keine der
preis zusage in und auswendig und pamina
ich habe jetzt das rollendebüt uns
wichtig ist dass ein anderer sozialer
dem europa - sony hat auf dem htc mozart
in salzburg spiel 100 jahr jubiläum
es hat viele grüne gärten trainiere ich
hoffe schon dass es stattfindet aber
habe für ablenkung sorgen unter anderem
im rahmen von kultur ausgestattet das
experiment mit sieben künstlerinnen und
künstler wozu deine krone der hype
liefert und jorge den alltag sie sind
täter mit der bi und sie hat sich selber
müsse vielmehr ist das schwierig wenn
man muss filme
also ich muss ihm das telefon den tod
drei dass ich mich mit gleichzeitig
sehen also muss ich immer wieder so hat
man nicht den kopf nicht ab schon hinter
das bild das bild stimmt liegt dass der
ton einigermaßen mithalten das auge muss
kontrollieren ob das vernünftig sind
ende der show das große vorträge und
aber taktisch vielleicht eine starke
buch noch einmal zurück auf die zeit um
sich zu erinnern was fragen der kopf
sind was ein beschäftigter vielleicht im
nachhinein spannend das auto dann nur
gerademal drei regula mühlemann und sagt
andere künstlerinnen künstler zu zieht
der krone ist das experimental platz
ihnen geht es nicht viel anders als uns
allen auch sie leben mit und in der
krise und für uns greifen sie in den
nächsten wochen zu ihren smartphones
die tänzerin lisa hortons kelbra die
violinistin kathrin koudelka der oboist
michael von schönermark die sängerin
regula mühlemann die kabarettistin uta
köbernick der schauspieler andrea zogg
und die video künstlerin veronika
spielen bord sie filmen sich selbst
einteilen mit uns ihre gedanken
hallo mein name ist uta köbernick und
ich bin kabarettistin schauspielerin und
mache lieder die von cantona
denn sein
franken
roger moore der schauspieler und
regisseur und meint damit aber aus der
diaspora künftig halbjahresprogramms
vollzeit im prättigau und nicht
[Musik]
und zeigen sein
von uns also ich will jetzt nicht für
alle unserer zunft sprechen aber wir
selbständigen künstlerinnen und künstler
wir sind ja immer auf das ja alles
abgesagt
aber eines können wir es aushalten wenn
der tag eine struktur hat
[Musik]
ich bin regelrecht opera und
konzertsängerin und mächtig die krone
krise wie man sich angekündigt
insofern dass natürlich alle konzert
abgesagt sind
[Musik]
ich liebe mich sehr gern auch ich finde
sie toll daran jetzt so schlimm ist
heimat geht was natürlich irgendwo in
tschechisch dass man eine weiße wand das
dass gott es ist ganz allgemein die
situation wo mir hüten sich
es liegt bis wir in betrieben und machen
es nicht wenn es nix sehen wie man der
virus nicht da haben wir das nicht
fassen ich sehe aber gespürt
das sind die bilder die uns andrea zogg
schickt zeigen ein verlassenes walz
einer auch hier ist kaum jemand
unterwegs
die videos von regula mühlemann zeigen
wie kochen und gemeinsames essen per
skype funktioniert
ihr startet mit der frühlingslauf mit
skype also manager willi wißing das ist
toll wenn man eigentlich sagen der woche
für eine echte termin der berühmte und
ton hat sammelt nach das und das
nachlassen wenn wir hoch also wir freuen
sich sehr fein zucker bei mir wechseln
die stimmung und die gedanken eigentlich
jeden tag beziehungsweise sie wechseln
nicht sie sind gleichzeitig da und
kämpfen um ihre vorherrschaft
panik ist allerdings nicht dabei und ich
glaube das liegt daran dass ich in der
ddr aufgewachsen bin und die wende
erlebt habe und dass sich die welt
binnen kurzer zeit völlig verändern kann
also dass ich auch in dieser zeit für
sich jeden tag dinge um 180 grad drehen
können dass bewertungen von
sachverhalten oder die
schlussfolgerungen die aus daraus
gezogen werden dass die sich ändern oder
eben einfach das ausnahmezustand
herrscht und dass ich dass ich keine
auskennt mit diesem zustand kenne ich
mich aus
und das macht mich ruhig wachsam und
fast gelassen
[Musik]
berlin 180 c mehr brauchen ich schaue
jetzt hätte kapitalismus kein feind mir
jetzt kann das excel beruf fresser und
dass ich in der lippstädter die ski oder
algen traum basiert und ihren imbiss
erwartet aber was jetzt noch wirklich
dass sie schon vorstellbar oder und das
kann man sich nicht ausdenken was tun
wird das müssen die rgm
deshalb hat andrea zogg mit seiner frau
einen youtube kanal ins leben gerufen
bei dem jeder und jede texte und
gedanken einreichen kann die er dann
vorträgt immer noch alles dicht
willkommen bei radio tv waal seiner
kritiker ja sehr bald mehr werden nicht
ganz freiwilliger quarantäne und nächste
woche zeigen wir wie opel via skype
unterrichtet wird und wie eine tänzerin
vom ballett des theaters basel in
quarantäne weiter trainiert
und weiter geprobt betagte um kranke
menschen sind besonders hart getroffen
vom virus denn sie sind jetzt noch mehr
isoliert aus auch schon
und genau für diese menschen soll jetzt
die musik spielen diese idee hatte die
opernsängerin stefanie braun und hat
flugs ein projekt auf die beine gestellt
mit dem namen love serenade ein starkes
zeichen in zeiten der krise ein
musikprojekt auf drei rädern
platz alina da ist spontan hilfe für all
jene die von der korona krise besonders
schwer betroffen sind alte geschwächter
und einsame menschen im zürcher
alterszentrums park etwa kein dschungel
schutzmasken desinfektionsmittel und
teppich inseln gehören zum
instrumentarium das infizierte die
steckdosen und instrumente die werden
auch noch mal dessen findet die vom bund
verordneten hygienemaßnahmen wollen
eingehalten werden
was motiviert denn die musiker dazu
solche mühen auf sich zu nehmen
der traum oder die vision wäre
eigentlich dass es bald in jeder stadt
eine serie nato gibt weil dieser alten
menschen jedoch unter der isolation noch
viel mehr leiden als vielleicht die
jüngeren die wir auch online gehen
können und uns mit diesen sachen auch
schon viel besser auskennen sie können
hier ihre enkel nicht mehr sehen sie
können keinen besuch mehr kommen lasse
die nato ist bislang ein reines
wohltätigkeitsprojekt browns hoffnung
ist dass diese idee ein selbstläufer
wird und auch andere musiker auf diesem
weg freude verbreiten
wir danken ihnen kommen sie gesund
gesund durch diesen frühling und wir
hoffen wir sehen sie an einer anderen
stelle dann auch wieder alles liebe
vielen dank glas renata kann übrigens
über die eingeblendete website gebucht
werden
wenn wir das schaffen würden dass wir
überall diese menschlichkeit und dieses
verbindende gefühl wieder haben könnten
dann hätten wir alle ganz ganz viel
gewonnen in dieser zeit von der wir alle
nicht wissen wie lange es eigentlich
noch gehen wird
zu hoffen bleibt dass die musiker bald
wieder konzertsäle fiel denn auch für
sie fallen gerade viele einnahmen weg
nein
ja diesen und andere kulturtipps
übrigens die finden sie jederzeit auch
auf unserer website
die kultur die findet ihre bühnen auch
mitten in der krise das ist
beeindruckend das macht mut denn wir
müssen ja alle noch ein bisschen
durchhalten vernünftig sein und vor
allem wenn immer möglich zu hause
bleiben
nächste woche nehme ich sie mit ihnen
ein museum ohne menschen die ja auch das
naturhistorische museum in bern ist
natürlich momentan geschlossen
wir dürfen trotzdem rein um darüber zu
berichten was als nächstes das thema an
steht dort und das ist nicht weniger als
der weltuntergang schlimmer geht immer
gleich jetzt folgt eine neue schweizer
serie kleine lügen teil eins gleich nach
und kommen sie gut durch die woche
bleiben sie gesund
schneider
b
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos